hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
denke jeder kennt mittlerweile die
plattform musical total ist es halt eine
plattform wo jeder mensch auf der welt
sich aufnehmen kann zu einem lied was
schon existiert von einem anderen
künstler macht dringlich mundbewegungen
oder schneider dazu irgendwann jesse
kelly ich heiße der reeser luca und es
gibt auch musical so verschiedene arten
von usern heißen die glaube ich oder
musical land kombis auf youtube
beispielsweise den gamer den entertainer
die beauty tante gibt et cetera gibt es
auch musical halt auch so verschiedene
arten von nutzern der plattform ich bin
mir der plattform selber erst seit ein
paar tagen angemeldet aber selbst mir
ist es schon aufgefallen welche
verschiedenen formen es von
verschiedenen menschen dort gibt die
verschiedene sachen deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht die zehn sachen die mir
direkt aufgefallen sind zeige ich euch
mal der sich geil fühlende
[Musik]
mio
das zeigt eine sache deswegen musical
von sehr vielen leuten gehärtet wird
wird dir die plattform an sich ist ultra
cool also die blocken direkt alle leute
bzw alle kommentare die irgendwie sowas
sagen die [ __ ] oder stimmt doch
oder sowas und der sinn der plattform
ist auch ultra cool also leute die nicht
singen können beziehungsweise die können
ja vielleicht sogar singen aber die
können sich einfach irgendeinen blieb
neben war schon existiert und darauf
einfach ihren mund bewegen so die idee
zu simpel und cool allerdings wird es
wirklich von vielen jüngeren leuten die
irgendwie so 13 bis 17 sind dafür
genutzt ihre pubertierende schönheit
irgendwie so in die kamera zu stellen
und musical ist einfach so aus wie ich
euch das bringt gezeigt habe also
irgendein lied die machen irgendwas
einem drop fast nicht durch die haare
denken sie sind die allermeisten und das
ist falsch
also die plattform ist finde ich nicht
für so was geeignet sondern einfach
dafür dass leute mit kreativen ideen
dann kommen und darauf irgendwie das war
aber egal der der den text nicht trifft
[Musik]
als kleines bonbon feiertag
solche leute trifft man nicht überall
also es wissen beim musical i nimmt man
normalerweise so videos auf in dem man
das lied in halber geschwindigkeit
abspielt man singt in halber
geschwindigkeit und dann wird das halt
zur normalen wie schwierig der buch
gestützt so dass das ganze so ein
bisschen mehr user aussieht allerdings
kommen sehr viele leute mit dieser
geschwindigkeit umstellung nicht so ganz
klar und treffen ist im text nicht und
wir machen weiter mit nummer drei das
mädchen
muss ich glaube ich nicht zu sagen gibt
es auch auf instagram aktive leute mit
irgendeiner kern und total lippen und
diebels viel make-up und dann stehen da
irgendwie so ist glaube ich alles schon
gesagt und gezeigt worden ist
[Musik]
sie macht eigentlich auf musicals
gleiche wie auf youtube
sie nutzt die plattform komplett falsch
und präsentiert nur ihren körper die
choreographie
[Musik]
finde ich an sich mega cool also leute
denken sich echt teilweise solidere
übelste sachen haus in meinem beispiel
habe ich das halt gerade in einer
sekunde gemacht und deswegen satz
relativ scheiße aus aber es gibt leute
bei musicali da sieht man wirklich dass
sie sich bei einem lied eine woche
gedanken gemacht haben sich damit
freunden zusammen gesetzt haben und dann
machen alle irgendwie so komische moves
und alles so zeitgleich und so dass es
ich habe mich gerade geschlagen
die zwillinge
wie der beste kicker seitdem diese 12 13
14 jährigen ich weiß nicht ganz genau
lisa und lena so geheilt wurden machen
sich immer mehr zwillinge auch musical
über sie denken sie können das gleiche
phänomen schaffen ist ja an sich auch
echt coole leute geht er halt zum mega
drauf ab weil meistens machen dass der
erste reine personenschäden geht die so
zur seite der liste hat eine zweite
person ja also das waren die zwillinge
das jazz label aggro ab kind
muss ich glaube ich nicht mehr viel zu
sagen das haben schon sehr viele andere
youtuber übernommen es ist halt ultra
krass und zwar die zeigen bilder von
sich wie die jung waren und machen dabei
den drop wieder wie sie heute aussehen
und die sind dann vielleicht ein jahr
älter oder so wählt die ganzen leute von
denen ich das bisher gesehen habt sind
eh schon relativ jung dieser jazz label
aggro up trend geht auch so ein bisschen
ein herr mit dem was ich als erste schon
gezeigt hatte mit dem sich geil fühlen
denn weil folgte das halt nutzen um
gleich alten bilder von sich zu zeigen
wo sie hässlich aussehen und dann drop
sondern sowie die one direction 2.0
[Applaus]
cg
[Musik]
sehe ich auch ultra oft auf musiker
lieder sind irgendwelche leute die sich
zu viert vor die kämen setzten sich halt
irgendwie schminken gegen wie das licht
passend einstellen
da habt ihr gerade mal meine freundin
gesehen aber ja also beim pärchen videos
ist es halt auch zu dass sie irgend
track nehmen von wegen ich liebe dich
ich will dich nicht mehr verlieren ich
liebe dich über alles liebe nicht bis
zum boden zurück und dann gucken sie
sich die sun und lächeln die ganze zeit
und ist ja schön und süß aber ich finde
es ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben zu
guter letzt laser luca tschechische
fußballer bin ich stärker bin ich
geboren und damian nocon ja so sein
musical ist von mir also von mir da das
war es von video meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen folkmusic die
habe ich jetzt lebe ich schon oft genug
eingeblendet ich liebe die plattform
einfach weil es keine form von heldt
gibt man kann quasi perfekt mit
einschreiben ich weil ich geh da derzeit
auch fast alle kommentare ein und
beantwortete die weil er einfach derzeit
noch so wenig kommentare kommt also dass
ist so mit abstand plattform wo ich
derzeit am aktivsten unterwegs bin von
vielen musicals einfach gehalten weil
sie das nur aus solchen youtube videos
kennen wo sich leute darüber lustig
machen aber es liegt einfach daran die
plattform an sich ist geil was einige
pubertierende kinder daraus machen ist
einfach falsch
deswegen die plattform